freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
heutigen video ich freue mich sehr
dieses video endlich zu machen dies
wieder aufzuladen für euch des lebens
hat den von einem neuen format wie ihr
vielleicht wisst freddy kopf gerne ich
koche gerne treffe also strom waffe
macht das ganze schon ein bisschen
länger endlich aber ich würde sagen dass
ich auch ganz gut drauf aber daraus ist
der gedanke entsprungen wir also fremde
müssen uns betteln wir müssen gucken wer
kann verschiedene gerichtet besser zu
bereiten ich bin so jemand der bei
solchen geschichten immer sehr ehrgeizig
ist und sich immer viel mühe gibt und
ich kann nur soviel sagen für freddy
wird das ganze überhaupt nicht leicht
heute haben direkt eine besonderheit und
2 tbyte freddy zeitgleich auch ein video
online gegangen in zukunft wird das
ganze so stattfinden das einmal pro
woche eine folge erscheint und dann
werden wir immer in der zubereitung
einer speise bett wenn also bester
bürger beste pizza
das ist aber nicht die einzige
besonderheit dass heute gleich zwei
videos online kommt sondern wir haben
auch ein partner heute aber wie ich so
wie ihr denkt mit kohle oder so schaut
man ja das ist ein paket von der fetten
coakley für leute die nicht aus köln
kommen war ein bisschen lustig die fette
kuh ist ein burger land in der kölner
südstadt und jeder kölner liebt dass
wirklich jeder kölner gibt das so genau
so aufregend ich wir kriegen keine kohle
wir haben aber dieses paket hier
bekommen das hat es in sich hier ist
nämlich alles drin was man zur
zubereitung eines burgers überhaupt
freddy an aus und paket bekommen aber
mit einem anderen burger und jetzt
werden wir schauen wer von uns kriegt
das ganze besser hin und wer von uns
holt den ersten punkt in unserem bett
ich habe selbst keine ahnung was hier
drin
ist aber ich bin sehr gespannt und ich
würde sagen wir schauen mal gemeinsam
ein trading ist jetzt am apparat bist du
bist du bereit nicht nur bereit
ich habe auch richtig angst ich habe da
mal gesprochen mit bridge ist wir können
gleich 70 minuten sind wir dann da wird
wir dürfen auch nicht zu schnell seien
zwei bei mir auch so weiterläuft auch
okay gesehen und hab mir erstmal
umschlag von mexiko gekommen dazu und
wir gucken mal gemeinsam
da sollte schon alles drin stehen soweit
ich bin höchst auftritt das geld das ist
der echte hilfen magst du weißt es ja
selbst dass corona hat der gastroszene
alles abverlangt werden immer noch
geblockt sondern möchten trotzdem nicht
den kopf in den sand stecken und so
tollen gäste und die support your local
bewegung geben uns immer wieder
ultimative motivation wir sind im
letzten jahr kreativ geworden und haben
uns überlegt was wir anbieten können und
wofür unsere handwerklichen fähigkeiten
nutzen können unsere mystery box gibt er
einen einblick in unsere neu
entstandenen produkte und lässt auch
dich kreativ werden
wir freuen uns auf die umsetzung eines
persönlichen clown mystery burgers le
clos die zeit läuft allerdings die zeit
läuft darf man alles sofort ok hinten
drauf das rezept der sportverein
die zeit läuft bereits ja hallo habe ich
wir sind bei 58 minuten die ich noch
habe bis wir uns mit sturm die treppen
hoch wartet das hätte richtig gelesen
baut ein grill auf hier erstmal eine
kühl von der fed
das hier ist lancia wahrscheinlich ein
grillrost oder so eine gasflasche
ultimatives burger steak und barbecues
eisblöcken bacon jam teriyaki soße süß
saurer soße sesamöl also wir sind sehr
asiatisch schon mal unterwegs tube
mayonnaise reisberger bands und hier
unten drin ist ein grill den bau ist als
erstem aufhielten stelle ich mal den
teilweisen dass wir immer gucken kann
wie viel zeit aus
perfekt der ist auch richtig schwer sehr
gut unser grill steht wir haben auch gar
nicht einig ob etwas arbeit hört ihr
wort mit sojasprossen hühnerfüßen
dann bin ich komplett aus althütte
besser weiß ja auch klar mystery burger
okay das ist ein bisschen kraft wir
werden nicht unbedingt attraktiv ich
denke mal das wird eher so ein deko
element sein könnte mir gut vorstellen
dann haben wir hier auch rindfleisch das
geht schon sehr gut aus muss man sagen
das haben die jungs glaube ich auch
heute morgen frisch gebeugt
hähnchenschenkel butter schaschlikspieß
noch mehr vögel kopfschüsse also 3 150
milliliter mario von den 50 davon der
chili society ist von der marke festina
also das wird echt jede menge mio das
showcar ist also im april eröffnen wir
ein teelöffel unterzogen ein bisschen
schade dass die hardware dazu dann haben
wir schon mal die soße fertig im
nächsten schritt gehe ja auch schon das
heißt ich bereite erstmal alle unsere
zutaten richtig vor damit wir sicher
gehen dass alles passt hier haben mir
einmal ein ausgelösten hähnchenflügel
der soll komplett gehen nämlich mal auf
den burger bekommt ist sehr heiß weil
die haut sehr knusprig wird unser wie
für das partie wird auf jeden fall
ordentlich habe also einer der viel
masse art für ein bürger dieses ganze
zeug schon mächtig wir jetzt natürlich
noch unsere hähnchen füße termin aber
gedacht damit das ganze ein bisschen
ansehnlicher ist frith ihre ich die
hähnchen füße weil wir haben ja eine
jury heute und glaube es ist nicht
unbedingt falsch wenn man kann man das
ein bisschen mehr nach caves die
aussicht lässt
kurz die box an die seite ja noch eine
halbe stunde zeit was eigentlich sehr
komfortabel ist um die künste zu
frittieren stellt jetzt mal hier einen
verbrauch und las ein bisschen ölreiche
dieses video heute dient quasi so ein
bisschen dazu um euch das format erst
mal ein bisschen näher zu bringen
später werden wir das ganze aber so
machen dass wir uns deutlich weniger
vorgaben geben als heute
da einfach schauen wer bessere rezepte
wie er in der gleichen zeit zu bereiten
kann es wird also sehr spannend bis nur
noch weniger als eine halbe stunde zeit
mit 28 nur noch also ich glaube da muss
ich wirklich ein besonderer ich kriege
noch rüber gehen ja es muss jetzt halt
sehr viel gleichzeitig laufen reicht
aber eigentlich bin ich gar nicht mal so
schlecht in der zeit
es wird lange 123 minuten auch ich
bereit hier das thema fort was ich die
ganzen also ich kenne es einmal ein
bisschen durch und formen daraus eine
kugel die ganzen sachen die wir haben
müssen vorbereitet sind vorbereitet ist
auch sehr gut so
ich glaube ich fange gleich schon mal an
und lege das chickens bergauf aber
wieder vorbereitung schnell die klaus
burk das sind schuhe sind würden
ordentlich habe auf jeden fall gibt die
einfach einmal so strömen ins heiße öl
okay leute wir legen jetzt auf den grill
auch wir legen auf erstmal auf die
unterseite dann schauen wir auch schon
mal drunter
jetzt drehen wir das ganze das steht
zwar nicht so ein rezept aber ich
verstehe ja aber es war ein game
vermutlich das ganze zu beschweren
werden
oder nehmen jetzt auch das männchen
runter und machen weiter mit unserem
special so wollen ich habe noch zehn
minuten und ich muss das ganze gleich
noch über bringen also crazy hier
klicken
das heißt man kann das ganze endlich sei
es braucht sagen natürlich der bürger
pfeffer aber sparsam damit umgehen oder
es wird schön knusprig so unsere
sportler ist jetzt auch fertig dann
schmerzlich ein wenig butter an so schön
knusprig sein dann bauen wir jetzt auch
schon zusammen
ordentlich man unserer mario unterseite
stadt bacon benutzen wir treten jam
gehen wir einfach auf unser paddy drauf
war
so habe das auch die unterseite von
burger dann kaufe auch schon das chicken
steak dann auf die oberseite ein paar
sojasprossen wirklich nur so alibi und
dann machen wir das ganze zu der welt
jetzt kommt noch unsere spezialität
drauf damit kann man das ganze auch
gleich viertel und dann geht es jetzt
nur noch unsere bürger zu nehmen und so
schnell wie es geht zur location zu
gehen wo wir testen
[Musik]
schneider singt eimer wir sind fertig
geworden und wir gehen jetzt zur
location hey herzlich willkommen am ende
dieser videos wir laden ja bei
gleichzeitig hoch das ist ja von unserem
neuen format ich fragte sie sich nicht
so moment mal in kunst ist doch
eigentlich jetzt die ausrüstung also das
ende aber wir haben das zusammen gefilmt
schon unsere sd karte leider ein
geschützten deswegen machen wir es noch
mal neue damit es auch ein vernünftiges
videos und erwähnte datei nicht im
ausschuss leider durch das gesamte ende
vom video schrott aber wir haben
trotzdem ich sehe doch für euch und ihr
seht jetzt wie unsere tester die sind
durch nacheinander alle in sprints
bekommen haben dort gesessen haben
gegessen haben ihr votum abgegeben und
dann haben wir sie wieder
rausgeschmissen die aber wir haben den
jungs die getestet haben unsere jury
waren gesagt wir haben es verkackt könnt
ihr nochmal ein kleines video chat mit
eurer bewertung und das ist ihm die
bürger von den beiden jungs war auf
jeden fall die schlechte er von schumi
war leider schon ein bisschen kalt
pommes waren auch wirklich ja ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich will nicht reden aber
waren schon kalt war schon ein bisschen
logik so das war auf jeden fall nicht so
top job top maxis war ein bisschen
wärmer noch aber diese hühnerfüße da
oben drauf oder in gott man klar ist nur
dass jetzt nicht so seine schuld er das
einmal so bekommen aber wieder füße ich
habe eine weile wirklich hin und her
überlegt das findest du mir jetzt auch
gut gemacht der hat kreativ gemacht für
den max hat auch das beste draus gemacht
er hat die hühnerfüße haus selbst von
hand paniert so finde ich richtig krass
es tut mir leid
am ende muss ich muss ich die punkte
nicht wieder für sein gewinn zu brauchen
also ich muss sagen freddys bürger da
war auf jeden fall on fire
aber ich muss natürlich sagen weil die
zeit natürlich auch das
nein aber da war echt ganz gut max fand
ich auch ganz besonders die kommen mit
dem schicken und im beef aber ich bin
für die nach langer überlegung bin ich
zu dem entschluss gekommen
mich auch im nachhinein noch für sturm
mitbürger zu entscheiden weil mir mehr
kommt die wichtigste komponente eines
bürgers nämlich das fleisch da einfach
besser geschmeckt hat bekommt jetzt
nicht so krass oder so dass einiges
schwarzbrot aber da habe ich jetzt das
habe ich nicht so krass gefühlt aber das
ist nicht so wichtig also bei max hat
mich gestört dass der jetzt
zusammenspiel zwischen oder ticken und
wie das war so ein bisschen eis und im
nächsten bisschen war es wieder so habe
ich einfach nicht so gefühlt deswegen
entscheide ich mich letztendlich
tatsächlich schon mit bürger eingebracht
ja eher sollen glückwunsch dass es so
gut geklappt hat mit den aufnahmen ich
mache das aber für euch natürlich gerne
noch mal also studiums berger hat mir
sehr gut gefallen ich stehe auf scharfe
soße genau mein ding schwarzer bahnen
als special dazu hat spaß gemacht in
essen das spaß macht sehr sehr gut max
berger muss ich sagen hat mich auf den
ersten blick ein bisschen abgestoßen mit
fast vier meter platz max burger hat
mich auf den ersten blick ein bisschen
abgestoßen durch den chicken fuß die
zwei fleisch dort haben wir aber gut
gefallen die soße war es toll in all
muss ich aber leider sagen das tut mir
leid max dass ich auf sturm
hätte ich nicht gedacht wenn ich ganz
ehrlich wo haben wir auch so lag es bei
dir und deswegen die ich habe so ein
bisschen die winterferien verdacht ich
hab mir trotzdem ich kann nur soviel
sagen ich kann aber in der nächsten
woche sehen wir auf meinen kanal ist
richtig die nächste folge und ich kann
nur soviel sagen dieser junge mann
begleiten
bis zum nächsten mal